that was such a nice introduction I feel
like I should be lying down in a coffin
right now hmm and I hope you're I feel
like I should toast you
you and your liquor and I find it funny
that I'm a theater named for F scott
Fitzgerald is a serving hard alcohol
during my reading okay I guess then you
can finish here and go back to all of
your own personal crack-ups I am a
history buff I am one one 800-number
away from ordering the time-life World
War two series off the TV I have set my
alarm so I wouldn't miss a c-span
morning live remote from the house of
the Revolutionary War pamphleteer Thomas
Paine I celebrated my 30th birthday at
Grant's Tomb
my airport reading material a
novelization of Gettysburg here a Lyndon
Johnson biography there always receives
an approving glance from whatever
middle-aged man on my flight is perusing
the new stephen ambrose book because
every domestic flight requires a
middle-aged man with a Stephen Ambrose
book in his carry-on luggage it's an FAA
regulation
the historical periods I like to learn
about aren't so much costume dramas as
slasher flicks the French Revolution is
a favorite because it features the
beloved plot of carnage in service of
democracy but I prefer American history
and if I had to pick my pet domestic
bloodbath nothing beats Salem or
Gettysburg I'm a sucker for Puritan New
England in the Civil War
because those two subjects feature the
central tension of American life
the conflict between freedom and
community between individual will and
the public good that is a fancy way of
hinting that sometimes other people get
on my nerves Puritanism and the War
Between the States inspired some of the
greatest American writing scary sermons
and Lincoln speeches
writing which asked to me the question
if you are so gung-ho on the fellowship
of your countrymen why have you had your
phone off the hook for the last four
days I revere the idea of the Union
adore that phrase of Lincoln's when he
asked the country to carry on with
malice toward none and one of the
prettiest Puritan sermon the city upon a
hill one John Winthrop delivered on a
ship approaching Massachusetts in 1630
he aspired toward a covenant of
community decree
we must delight in each other make
others conditions our own rejoiced
together mourn together labor and suffer
together having before our eyes our
commission and community in the work our
community as members of the same body
are there any nobler words than that and
yet did Winthrop ever live next door to
a neighbor who was training a puppy
would he have been so keen on us
suffering together if he had just awoken
two screams of naughty naughty no no
the most bizarre episode in Puritan
history is the Salem witch trials 20
innocent people were executed in Salem
during the witchcraft hysteria of 1692
which is horrifying
yet manages to make for a surprisingly
nice weekend getaway
Salem boasts everything you would want
from a trip down American memory lane
from information to anxious giggles
there's the which dungeon Museum a place
about as dignified as it sounds there's
a colorful old guy walking tour guide
named Bob who says things like they hug
dogs for being witches that's how stupid
these people were and there there are a
few yellowing historical documents to
look at in the Peabody Essex Museum so
that I don't feel like a total cheese
ball even though I just bought a whiskey
glass emblazoned with a little yellow
highway sign with a silhouette of a hag
on a broomstick that says witch crossing
on July 19 1692 a woman named Sarah
Goode stood on the gallows and answered
the minister making a last-ditch effort
to get her to confess to witchcraft she
famously proclaimed to the Reverend and
I'm guessing the town you are a liar I
am no more a witch than you are a wizard
and if you take away my life God will
give you blood to drink could you have
any idea then that three centuries later
bloodthirsty tourists would sip her life
story from a souvenir shot glass what
would she think of the local ice cream
parlor going by the name Derry which or
that the high school football team is
called the Salem witches or that one of
my fellow tourists asked a gift shop
cashier if she was selling any
witchcraft trivets to which the cashier
replied you mean a trivet with a witch
on it
it is a disrespectful affront to the 20
people who lost their lives including
Giles Corey who was pressed to death to
such a grave injustice that this tourist
wants to remember his visit to their
hometown by purchasing an object to
protect his dining room table from a
boiling saucepan if I had to nail down
the objective of my historical tourism
it's probably to collect evidence in
support of my motto and my motto in any
given situation is could be worse it
could be worse is how I meet every
setback though nothing all that bad has
ever happened to me every time I've had
my heart broken or gotten fired or
watched an audience member at one of my
readings have a seizure as I stand at
the podium trying not to cry I remind
myself that it could be worse in my
self-help universe when things go wrong
I whisper mantras to myself mantras like
Andersonville or Texas School Book
Depository Andersonville is a code word
for you could be one of the prisoners of
war dying of disease and malnutrition in
the worst Confederate prison so just
calm down about the movie you wanted to
go to being sold out ever since I went
to Salem I'm keen on gallows Hill as in
being stuck in the Boise Airport for ten
hours while getting hit on by a divorced
man with major financial problems on his
way to his 20th high school reunion is
ergh some but not as dire as swinging by
the neck on Salem's gal
so if I have gleaned anything useful
from reading and day-tripping through
the tribulations of the long-dead its to
count my blessings to try and quit belly
aching buck up
can't you just hear the children's song
gallows Hill and Andersonville it could
be could be worse I'm hearing a breakout
of the story for a second I have a I
don't know if this is what you would
call a treat but I was doing this story
recently at a reading in the band They
Might Be Giants was also on stage and we
are trying to think of some way to be
interactive and so John Flensburg of
they might be giants and I actually
wrote this song iffy it could be worth
song which you know gallows Hill and
Andersonville is the chorus but
unfortunately I can't sing but not that
that's going to stop me but here I
thought I would share with you one of
the verses of the it could be worth song
you it's all about you know how the it's
all about the theme of the story which
is that the tribulation students of
history can put your own small problems
into some sort of context um you order
baked potato but they served you fried
that's not as sad though as the day the
music died okay
on the first day of school
when I was a kid the guy teaching
history and it was almost always a guy
wearing a lot of brown would prop up the
pompous same-old same-old about how if
we kids failed to learn the lessons of
history than we would be doomed to
repeat them which is true if you're one
of the people who grow up to run things
but not as practical if your destiny is
a nice small life
for example thanks to my 10th grade
world history textbooks chapter on the
Napoleonic Wars I know not to invade
Russia in the wintertime this
information would have been good for an
i-told-you-so toast at Hitler's New
Year's party in 1943 but for me knowing
not to trudge my troops through the snow
to Moscow is not so handy day to day the
more history I learned the more the
world fills up with stories just the
other day I was in my neighborhood
Starbucks waiting for the post office to
open I was enjoying a chocolaty cafe
mocha when it occurred to me that to
drink a mocha is to gulp down the entire
history of the new world from the
Spanish exportation of Aztec cacao and
the Dutch invention of the chemical
process for making cocoa on down to the
capitalist Empire of Hershey PA and the
lifestyle marketing of Seattle Starbucks
the modern mocha is a bittersweet
concoction of imperialism genocide
invention and consumerism served with
whipped cream on top
no wonder it cost so much and thanks to
Sophie and my Coco's book the true
history of chocolate I remembered that
cacao beans were used as currency at the
moment of European contact when
Christopher Columbus's son Ferdinand
captured a Mayan canoe in 1503 he
noticed that whenever one of the natives
dropped a cacao bean they asked you to
pick it up as if an eye had fallen when
you know such trivia and act as mundane
as having an overpriced breakfast drink
becomes imbued with meaning even poetry
plus I read a women's magazine article
called five fabulous morning rituals and
it said that after you bask in bed and
walk in nature
you're supposed to ponder the sins of
the conquistadors um yeah that story
doesn't so much end a stop I guess
um thanks yeah okay now I couldn't be
more pleased because I I was informed
that this theater is where exactly where
Mondale and Coleman had their Senate
debate right I mean I don't recognize it
because I of course listen to it on
public radio but um
anyway that wasn't I was a good knows
good little debate um let's hope this
evening turns out a little better than
that
and didn't when Mondale conceded I mean
I wait like say what you will about
Democrats and their prowess but we
really know how to write a concession
speech you know what I'm saying anyway
so in that spirit I thought I'd read a
little excerpts from this story that's
it's kind of about a lot of things it's
sort of an allegory of jocks versus
nerds as witnessed through the 2000
presidential election and it's kind of
long so I'm just chopping out a lot of
stuff like I'm leaving out the whole
section on what the gore campaign could
have learned by watching Buffy the
Vampire Slayer because that's
self-explanatory and I figure if it's
Tuesday and you're here then you must
not watch the show Oh
VCR okay shoot um yeah because that's
too much pressure because I mean I think
spike is like killing people again right
and you would find that out tonight
um anywho but a lot of the story takes
place in and around this political email
group that I've been part of that was
following the presidential campaign in
2000 up through the present election
night on through to the inauguration and
everything and it was it was this group
that it was it was very involved so you
know you would check your email and then
there would be like if you didn't check
your email for a couple of days there
would be 75 messages waiting for you all
about Al Gore was that kind of thing it
was really fun
the political email group might be the
all-time nerdiest thing I've been
involved in and I say that as a person
who has been involved in public radio
and marching band all of us were outdoor
supporters of varying levels of
enthusiasm a bunch of nerds rooting for
a nerd Joel a group member from Brooklyn
describes it as this weird bastion of
totally out of touch liberalism a
typical message about a group member
Saturday night begins late Saturday
evening I finished reading about
inauguration date in The Washington Post
and the LA Times and ABC News Online and
MSNBC online etc a few of us went down
to Washington to watch the inauguration
Jack a Connecticut father of two drove
down in his Titanic dad van setting off
from his house in New Haven picking up
Deirdre and Paul in Milford and stopping
for Kevin and me in New York we're all
friends but this trip isn't an act of
friendship so much as the culmination of
a laborious process on the eve of our
road trip to the inauguration I wasn't
sure I was going it promised to be
depressing the forecast called for rain
the Kevin's email convinced me a
novelist given two grandiose electronic
orations Kevin is the group's dinosaur
an old-school Roosevelt style Democrat
out of fashion enough to go on and on
about the fate of the poor the unlucky
and the young his emails are grand WPA
murals commemorating the ordinary
yearning to live and work in an honest
earthy Republic more than anyone I know
Kevin would make the best president at
the same time he's the least electable
he's the biggest hothead in the group
which is saying something were not
settled people kevin implores us to
drive down to the inauguration to be
able to say to those of our children's
grandchildren's generation that at least
we were
not willing to let American democracy to
let America die without standing up and
being counted no pressure he continues
this is the real crucible of being a
true American now to stand up for what
we believe in without illusions without
any real hope that we will be able to
change anything
there will be no great new third party
to rescue us no grassroots revival of
the Democratic Party all there is is us
willing to stand up and say no he
actually talks like that in January 2001
it was hard to be a patriot without
sounding like a conspiracy theorist
walking to the mall on inauguration day
we ducked into the National Archives to
look at the Declaration of Independence
in the Constitution just to see if
they're still there
jack-jack chats with the guard about the
nuclear proof underground vault the
documents are lowered into every night
then it's on to the police checkpoint
the inaugural parade route is completely
blocked off and the only way in is
through checkpoints for the authorities
search all bags it's all over the news
that thanks to the healthy number of
expected protesters they've banned fruit
as well as sticks attached to protest
signs also giant puppets those things
could be used to hit another person
never mind that my club-shaped umbrella
is admitted without a word or that a
president endorsed by the NRA is so
apparently worried that a cantaloupe or
marionette might put out some spoil
sport thickeners I the cops must be
humoring us to check our bags as we are
the least threatening looking group of
people here even elderly Republican
ladies are more menacing than we are
because they have the guts to wrap
themselves in controversial mink pelts
we get to the muddy mall just as Chief
Justice William Rehnquist is wearing and
Dick Cheney is vice president from where
we stand the men are far away specs but
thanks to the CNN Jumbotron their faces
are bigger than the Capitol dome
Rehnquist as one of the five Supreme
Court justices who effectively gave Bush
the presidency was a particular object
of the group's email scorn we all boo
him then we booed Dick Cheney or rather
I would like to think that it's nothing
personal
but we are booing the fishy process that
got him here Staff Sergeant Alec team
ally of the United States Army Band
sings my country tis of thee I'm stunned
when Kevin boos him too
I asked him you're booing the army guy
you're booing my country tis of thee are
we against everything now yes he answers
we're against everything and boos louder
george w bush places his hand on the
same Bible that George Washington placed
his hand on in 1789 and repeats after
Rehnquist that he will to the best of my
ability preserve protect and defend the
Constitution of the United States I'm
sure he means it if he's actually
thinking about it but it's reassuring to
have that underground route that the
National Archives as a backup I told
myself I came down to protest but I
choose to display my dissent by bursting
into tears as Bush finishes up his oath
it's happened it's over he's it once I
was prepared for this even looking
forward to it because before I am a
democratic nerd I'm a civics nerd first
and last back before election day there
was a part of me the part of myself I
don't like that harbored a secret
perverse desire that Bush would defeat
Gore because a bush victory I thought
would offer me four illustrious years of
taking the high road I would be
dignified I would be wise unlike my
Republican brethren who poo pooed Bill
Clinton's legitimacy from the dick from
the get-go Texas congressman Dick Armey
speaking to Democratic colleagues
referred to him as your president I
would be a bigger person during the
Clinton era being a civics nerd of any
political stripe was like having the
school bully paste a kick me sign on
your back every day year after year in
my pre-election daydream of what a Bush
presidency might be like I imagined that
I would criticize his policies and
lambaste his statements with a
civic-minded nobility all my venom spite
and as long as we're dreaming impeccable
logic would be directed at ow
our president as in look how our
president is wrecking our country making
my pompous little fantasy come true
however hinged on one thing a majority
of people voting for Bush so now what
the CNN camera pans around the dais
seeing Bush embrace his ex-president
father seeing him shaking the now
ex-president Clintons hand Singur
clapping like a sad good sport all makes
me cry harder about the only person up
there I find myself happy to look at is
the former Republican senator and
presidential candidate Bob Dole I've
developed a soft spot for Dole because
he symbolizes a simpler more innocent
time in America when you could lose the
presidential election and like not
actually become the president
the colossal head of Bush President Bush
delivers his inaugural address on the
jumbotron
it is not terrible I find myself but
grudgingly agreeing with most of it
though it will be weeks before I feel
adult enough to admit that out loud he
says that the story of America is the
story of a slaveholding society that
became a servant of freedom I can't
stomach unquestioning jingoism today so
I'm relieved that he refers to the
slaves that's where my head's at right
now that mentioning the slaves would
cheer me up it's a reminder that hey we
enslaved people we deserve to have this
guy be our president on inauguration
date when Dan died were walking down the
mall toward the Lincoln Memorial past
all the giggling Republican faces it
felt like being stuck inside the cover
of that old Frank Sinatra album no one
cares it's the one where there's a party
going on and all the party goers are
smiling and dressed up and dancing but
Sinatra sits all alone at the bar
sighing into his whiskey glass
he has his coat on and he looks like
he's remembering better times I was once
a Washington in turn back when being a
Washington intern it was a goody-goody
model citizen thing for a young lady to
do it was during the Clinton
administration's bubbly first year I
moved into my new Adams Morgan apartment
the night before Yitzhak Rabine shook
Yasser Arafat's hand for the first time
on the White House lawn I thought I
could feel the world being saved a few
Metro stops away looking at all the
gleeful partisans on Bush's inauguration
day took me back that feeling of
Washington is ours oh how my friends and
I went coud with excitement in the fall
of 93 when we were seated at brunch a
couple of tables over from George
Stephanopoulos all the other nubile New
Democrats were smitten with George
though I myself had a little crush on
the sad-eyed
economic advisor Robert Rubin
I have looked forward to Gore's
Washington with Gore running the country
it would be different I would feel even
more at home Clinton had appealed to the
rock and roller in me the part of me
that went to Graceland and cried when
Kurt Cobain died and thinks about James
Brown's hair but gore appeals to the
real me the one who can still sing a
song from college German class about
which prepositions to use with the
accusative case dr. Kagan ona uma kusa T
Gore's pencil-neck tugs at my nerdy soul
I think the most lovable thing he has
ever said can be found in a sentence in
his 1992 book earth in the balance
ecology and the human spirit on page 67
he asks what happened to the climate in
Yucatan around 950
something about the specifics of that
query lit me up for the first time I
could see casting my ballot for a man
who would pose such a question it was
just so boldly arcane the kind of mind
that would wonder about temperature
variations on a Caribbean peninsula a
thousand years ago might have the
stomach to look into any number of
Americans peculiar concerns
paradoxically this fervor for scientific
facts the thing that alienates him from
voters because they see him as cold
requires no small amount of passion you
don't write a 400 page book about
ecology unless you have the heart of
course gore being gore he doesn't write
just about what he knows
gore being gore he is compelled to
confess the dweebus details of how he
learned what he knows earth and the
balanced features countless hints that
his life is an ongoing study hall since
that time I have watched the mount of
lower reports every year or beginning in
January 1981 I spent many hours each
week for more than 13 months intensively
studying the nuclear arms race January
1981 he says I bet it was his new year's
resolution every other member of
Congress was vowing to cut back on the
hookers but then senator Gore probably
french-kiss tipper at midnight and made
a mental pledge to really get a handle
on those ICBMs
in the televised presidential debates
Bush did well enough on general
questions from his platform but on a
complicated question about what the
United States should do if ice did
Serbian president Milosevic refused to
leave office bush said he would ask the
Russians to lead the charge Vice
President Gore replied now I understand
what the governor has said about asking
the Russians to be involved and under
some circumstances that might be a good
idea but being as they have not yet been
willing to recognize Costa Nietzsche as
a lawful winner of the election I'm not
sure that it's right for us to invite
the president of Russia to mediate this
dispute there because we might not like
the result that comes out of that Bush
well obviously we wouldn't use the
Russians if they didn't agree with our
answer mr. vice president gore well they
don't
I don't understand why Gore didn't
secure a landslide right then and there
on knowledge alone it was a no-brainer
so why couldn't Gore carry his own home
state of Tennessee much less sweep the
rest of the country clearly it has
something to do with who he is as a
person and who he is as a person is a
big honking nerd nobody minds this in a
vice president the vice presidency is
actually a nerds perfect job a sidekick
is supposed to be a bigger geek than the
star like in the team TV drama my
so-called life when the dream boat boy
Jordan Catalano gets the telephone
number of a girl he doesn't know in two
seconds flat the nerd Brian Krakow asked
him this is like how you live how many
times Gore must have wanted to ask that
question of Clinton's
I wish you were different I wish that we
privileged knowledge in politicians that
the ones who know things didn't have to
hide it behind brown pants and that the
no not enough swirl aft all the way to
the main border on their first New
Hampshire meet-and-greet I wish that in
order to secure his party's nomination a
presidential candidate would be required
to point at the sky and name all the
stars have the periodic table the
elements memorized
rattle off the kings and queens of Spain
define the significance of the Gatling
gun interpret the symbolism in 17th
century Dutch painting explain
photosynthesis to a six-year-old recite
Emily Dickinson baked a perfect popover
build a shortwave radio out of a coconut
I know all the words to Hoagy
Carmichael's to sleepy people Johnny
Cash is five feet high and rising and
you got the silver by the Rolling Stones
after all the United States is the
greatest country on Earth dealing with
the most complicated problems in the
history of the world poverty pollution
justice Jerusalem what we need is a
president who has at least twelve kinds
of nerd a nerd Messiah to come along
every four years acquire the Secret
Service code name Poindexter
stallo Revenge of the Nerds screensaver
on the Oval Office computer and one by
one decrypt our woes
um I kind of read this little new piffle
thing I'm a couple of weeks ago the New
York Times op-ed page asked a bunch of
writers to do this and I guess what
happened maybe the the family I don't
know whoever owns the rights maybe it's
the Puzo the Mario Puzo estate it has
given the go-ahead so that some
publisher might be Random House I'm not
sure is is allowed to Commission a
sequel to The Godfather the novel and so
the New York Times op-ed page asked
people to imagine the beginning of that
book and this is mrs. mine on the day of
Angelina Corleone's commitment ceremony
to her longtime life partner
film producer Heather lippy her father
Don Vincent Corleone accepted an embrace
and a thick envelope of cash from his
concealed iary Tom Hagen the third Hagen
pulled a list of names from his jacket
pocket and handed it to Corleone the
people on the list had requested private
meetings with the Don taking advantage
of the old custom that no Sicilian can
refuse a request on his daughter's civil
union day the two men watched the widow
nary blush as the usher asked her bride
side or bright side
corleone drugged at hagen then winked
whispering hey it could be worse at
least my daughter's marrying an Italian
this is a part the times cut I don't
know why about your new daughter-in-law
Hagen wondered do we give her a job are
you kidding me
asked the dawn I want to be on her
payroll haven't you heard what she and
her cronies in the gay mafia did to that
bigwig at Disney poor guy woke up to
find a bunch of decapitated Mouse heads
bleeding all over us three thousand
thread count sheets that's it
hmm okay the finally I'll end with this
story and then we'll do a little Q&A and
tonight is very special night as you
know and it's the 239th anniversary of
the reading of the Gettysburg Address
whoo yeah I think that's why there's
liquor involved so anyway I have a
little story about the ceremony from two
years ago you know the big 237th mm-hmm
there are children playing soccer on a
field at Gettysburg where the Union Army
lost the first day's fight playing
soccer like a bunch of Belgians and in
the middle of football season no less
outside of town there's a billboard for
a shopping mall said to be the
Gettysburg Address for shopping standing
on the train platform where Abraham
Lincoln disembarked from Washington on
November 18th 1863 there's a Confederate
soldier a reenactor which direction is
South I asked him trying to recreate the
presidential moment when the fake Johnny
Reb replies that he doesn't know I scold
him dude you're from there
around the corner the citizens of
Gettysburg stand in line at the Majestic
Theatre for the 2:10 showing of meet the
parents Bennet the friend I'm with makes
a dumb joke about Lincoln meeting his
in-laws the Todd's things did not go
well he says it is November 19th 2000
the 137th anniversary of the cemetery
dedication ceremony at which Lincoln
delivered a certain speech four score
and seven years ago Lincoln said
referring to the Declaration of
Independence in 1776 our fathers brought
forth on this continent a new nation
conceived in Liberty and dedicated to
the proposition that all men are created
equal all they start with the good news
I realize the copy editor and the fact
checker in my head realized I said 239
it is the 139th I'm sorry so any of you
little public radio people who are just
waiting to like correct me on that later
save your breath hmm I could say I could
say that I've come to Gettysburg as a
rubbernecking tourist that I've shown up
to force myself to mull over the
consequences of a war I never think
about because that would make a better
story a gum-chewing youngish person who
says like too much comes face to face
with the horrors of war and learn
something but like the story isn't like
that fact is I think about the Civil War
all the time every day I can't even use
a cotton ball to remove my eye makeup
without spacing out about slavery's
favorite cash crop
I guess Gettysburg is a pilgrimage and
like all pilgrims I'm a mess you don't
cross state lines to attend the 137th
anniversary of anything unless
something's missing in your life the
fighting at Gettysburg took place
between July 1st and July 3rd 1863 the
Union under the command of General
George Meade won but not at first and
not with ease in the biggest bloodiest
battle ever fought on US soil 51,000 men
were killed wounded or missing I care
enough about the 51,000 to visit the
graves semicircular rows of stones with
the otherwise forgotten names of
Jeremiah Davis and Jesse wills and
Wesley rakes laid right next to Hiram
Hughes and little marble cubes engraved
with numbers assigned the unknowns who
was 811 or 775 the markers for the
unknowns are so minimal and so beautiful
I catch myself thinking of these men as
sculptures here they're called bodies
narrow slabs chiseled Massachusetts 159
bodies in Connecticut 22 bodies in
Wisconsin 73 bodies so I pay my respect
to the bodies but I'll admit that I am
more concerned with the 272 words
President Lincoln said about them in the
Gettysburg Address Lincoln said of the
men who shed their blood the world will
little note nor long remember what we
say here but it can never forget what
they did here who did he think he was
kidding we only think of them because of
him robert e lee hightailed it out of
gettysburg on the 4th of July
the same day the Confederates
surrendered Vicksburg to u.s. grant a
big deal at the time because it gave the
feds control of the Mississippi and yet
who these days dwells on Vicksburg
except for the Park Rangers who worked
there and a handful of sore losers who
whine when they're asked to take the
Stars and Bars out their God forsaken
state flags
the Gettysburg Address is more than a
eulogy it's a soybean a versatile little
problem solver that can be processed in
a seemingly infinite ingenious products
in this speech besides cleaning up the
founding fathers slavery mess by calling
for a new birth of freedom
Lincoln comforted grieving mothers who
would never bounce grandchildren on
their knees and ran for re-election at
the same time lest we forget he came to
Washington from Illinois even though we
think of him as the American Jesus he
had a little mayor Daly in him to
privately Lincoln has mixed feelings
about Gettysburg because he's certain
the war could have ended right here if
only general Meade had not let General
Lee get away because Lincoln is a good
man he does not say this in front of the
families who came to the cemetery to
hear that their loved ones shall not
have died in vain because he's a good
politician he looks on the bright side
though I personally suspect that in
Lincoln's first draft the line about how
it is for us the living rather to be
dedicated here to the unfinished work
which they who fought here have thus far
so nobly advanced was simply in his
first draft goddamn [ __ ] need
Abraham Lincoln is one of my favorite
writers the mystic chords of memory
better angels of our nature the father
of waters flows unvexed
to the sea all those brilliant phrases
I'd admired for so long and yet I never
truly thought of him as a writer until I
visited the David wills house in
gettysburg's Town Square in 1863 wills
was charged by Pennsylvania's governor
to oversee the battlefields cleanup and
the construction of the cemetery his
house now a museum is where Lincoln
stayed the night before delivering the
address I walk into the room where
Lincoln slept there's a gangly Lincoln
mannequin in white shirt sleeves hunched
over a small table his long legs poking
out the side
he's polishing the speech the myth is
that he wrote it on the back of an
envelope on the train but probably he's
been slaving over it for days and days
still he doesn't finish it until he's in
this room the morning of the 19th the
morning he's to deliver it to say that
Abraham Lincoln was a writer is to say
that he was a procrastinator
how many deadlines have I nearly blown
over the years slumped like Lincoln
fretting over words that didn't come out
until almost too late of course the
stakes are lower when one is under
pressure to think up insightful things
to say about the new Brad Pitt movie
instead of say saving the Union on the
other hand I've whipped out Aerosmith
record reviews that are longer than the
Gettysburg Address so where's my
mannequin
looking at Lincoln rushing to stave off
failure I felt so close to him let's say
I felt closer my grandest hope from my
own hastily written sentences is that
they would keep a stranger company on an
airplane Abraham Lincoln could turn a
pretty phrase such as I invoke the
considerate judgment of mankind and put
it on the proclamation that freed the
slaves even Mahler wouldn't claim to top
that at the Gettysburg National Cemetery
there's a ceremony every November 19th
to celebrate the anniversary of
Lincoln's speech I sit down on a folding
chair among the Shivering townspeople
the eminent Yale historian James
McPherson delivers a speech he may have
written a long time ago to make college
students feel bad because when he
accuses the audience of taking our
democracy for granted there's a rustling
in the crowd while people who
commemorate the anniversary of the
Gettysburg Address surely have a lot of
problems taking democracy for granted
isn't one of them New Jersey's then
governor christine Todd Whitman takes
the podium proclaiming our government
doesn't have all the answers and it
never will that is code for sorry about
that a key photo that shows me laughing
as I frisk an innocent black man on a
state police ride-along
I sit through all of this impatient I
didn't come here for the opening acts
Micah Van Halen concert goer who doesn't
high-five his friend until he hears the
first bird jump all I've been waiting
for is for the Lincoln impersonator
James Getty to stand up and read the
Gettysburg Address already this is what
Gary will says happened after Lincoln
stopped talking in 1863 the crowd walked
off from those curving graves on the
hillside under a change sky into a
different America this is what happened
after the Lincoln impersonator stopped
talking in the year 2000 the
eight-year-old boy sitting next to me
pointed at Getty and asked his mom isn't
that guy too short I glanced at the kid
with envy he's at that first great artsy
craftsy age when Americans learn about
Abraham Lincoln how many of us drew his
beard and crayon we built models of his
boyhood cabin with Elmer's glue and
toothpicks we memorized the Gettysburg
Address reciting its ten sentences in
stovepipe hats stapled out of black
construction paper the teachers taught
us to like Washington and to respect
Jefferson but Lincoln him we learned how
to love thank you
actually yeah
um you have just a few more minutes oh
maybe I'll read one more little short
thing since this is and we don't want to
dwell on that death story right and
since this is one of the one of those
cities of the seventies football glory I
thought I'd end on him Tarkington
come on I thought I'd end on this story
um well it's another death story but but
it's a cowboy who died so you might like
that
it's called Tom Landry existentialist
dead at 75 the front page obituaries
honoring the former Dallas Cowboys head
coach Tom Landry unimaginative Lee lists
only his most obvious achievements
leading America's team to five Super
Bowls between 1967 and 1988 playing and
coaching for the New York Giants in the
50s fathering three children and staying
married for 51 years
oh but his life had greater more
metaphysical manifestations at least to
me before Sartre before Kim Moo there
was Tom Landry he introduced me to
existentialism Tom Landry was my first
entrée into dread nagging doubting
gnawing fear and I'm not even referring
to the 79 Superbowl in which I crumpled
onto the living room carpet and wept as
my beloved Cowboys Oh Roger Staubach
quarterback my quarterback lost to the
Pittsburgh Steelers
the wound is still so fresh that to this
day I changed the channel every time the
then Steelers quarterback Terry Bradshaw
smug and shining pate pops out of my TV
can it be a coincidence that my own
first love was a spitting image of
Bradshaw and that he set my fifth tender
fifteen-year-old heart out to dry only
to hack it into strips of jerky which he
chewed up and swallowed in his pale
green car while singing along with
Frankie Goes to Hollywood oh I learned
things from the 79 Superbowl
disappointment upset - dreams etc but
those things combined to not necessarily
add up to existentialism proper I also
learned just weeks before the game at
Christmas that my mother had no
understanding of the NFL what with its
separate players and teams and all
because when she sent a football for
Roger Staubach to sign for me it came
back with a signature beautiful
penmanship but also covered in Dallas
Cowboys stickers due to the fact that
the ball my mother had sent Starr back
to sign was a Joe Namath
so nameís name was blocked with little
gray and blue helmets and despite this
faux pas Staubach sent me frame team
pictures two years in a row with Terry
Bradshaw have been that gracious that
forgiving would he
no the existentialism came up in the
offseason as I read my Tom Landry
Christian comic book my Pentecostal
youth was awash in salvation
testimonials that consistently backfired
meant to inspire young Protestants with
tales of redemption more often than not
these books and films and stories clued
me into the horrors of the world I
learned of knife fights from the Pat
Boone flick the cross and the
Switchblade a paralysis from the story
of Johnny a girl who had her spine
snapped in a diving accident got saved
and then had a promising art career by
painting flowers and things with a brush
stuck between her teeth of the Holocaust
when I was five as my mother read carton
bones the hiding place in which Dutch
Christians hid Jews and from my Landry
comic book I had my first inkling of the
Being and Nothingness that was my
birthright in the comic Landry in
signature coat and hat looked back on
his youth he said that as a player he
won games he said that he fell in love
got married had children became a coach
and then he said the thing that shocked
to me he said that despite the wins the
love the success the family he said that
something was missing that is until he
accepted Jesus Christ as his personal
Savior but before that something was
missing
I gasped I thank the Lord for my
certainty which was the certainty of Tom
Landry faith in God in the Cowboys in
America it never occurred to me that
something might be missing and so I
prayed every night that when I grew up
nothing would be missing prayed that
prayer every night up until the day I
lost my faith in God and Tom Landry
would be happy to know something has
been missing ever since different things
at different times if not love than
success if not success then supplies who
hasn't known the terror of that moment
when you're baking the cake and the oven
is preheated and you've mixed in
everything creamed the butter with the
sugar floured the pans only to realize
that you're out of baking powder every
day I wake up and wonder what will be
missing today looking back on Landry's
work in the theory of something is
missing this I am reminded of the words
of his existential colleague jean-paul
Sartre who wrote man is condemned to be
free and to die
rest in peace Tom Landry something is
missing and it's you
okay um so now spotlight on you we'll
have a QA I guess you have to actually
leave your seats which I don't I don't
know if um I know this is Minnesota nice
but I'm we the microphones are down
there um sir went up in the balcony I
guess not
maybe if you're in the I guess you have
to come down hmm
you must really have a question if oh
there's another balcony even now there
are microphones up there huh
no I guess not so anyway the first brave
little soldier has to come down it's
it's up to you I get paid either way
Oh
a rebel all right is that that's what
it's going to be um
the question is how's my driving I guess
you're referring to the documentary I
made in which my boss taught me how to
drive well I did learn but I never got
the license and I live in New York City
so I don't drive
great story huh what's John Linnell like
oh um this crap
John Linnell is member of they might be
giant um let's see what is he like he
he's such a racist no I'm just kidding
he's a very nice lovely very smart
charming fellow um I don't really have
any dirt on him at all he's a good
father a loving husband and a kind
friend he should move to Minnesota named
my favorite Johnny Cash song hmm
interesting
I could get really bogged down well mmm
you'll have to edit out this dead air if
they broadcast on us on the radio well I
mean I there's I don't know that I can
choose I certainly love a certainly
loved Ring of Fire and I really like the
trumpet arrangement in that very curious
don't you think mariachi trumpets I love
I love love love his version on you know
I love these last four records he's made
as a as a grown up
and there's that version he does have
the beast in me I could listen to that
all the time and in fact and I pick a
lot of the songs that we play on this
American life and our like running joke
is that after every This American Life
story we can always play the beast in me
because a lot of this American life
stories are like should I've done that
you know so I do like that song if asked
would I write a speech for a president
well this is clearly incredibly
hypothetical um I mean I guess I
wouldn't say no that would be a big
honor right but I mean I it would it
would probably have to take place in the
future
I mean nobody you can me at this
president asked me to write a speech and
I could say whatever I want sure who
wouldn't well well I marry him is the
question
um well sure since I can't really see
you and I just trust me to not know me
is to love me yeah it's all fine from
like a thousand yards away
if I could say something what would I
say to Paul Wellstone oh I'm not going
to touch that I don't know if any of you
read that aqui aqui peggy noonan a bad
thing where she wrote in the voice of
senator Wellstone oh you should look it
up on the web is maybe the grossest
thing ever written as my friend said
since MIT since mine comp and maybe
including mine from its I don't want to
get into that but yeah I should look it
up it's all maybe some of you were there
it's all in the voice of Senator
Wellstone up addressing his constituents
and loved ones after the memorial
service and what he senator Wellstone
thinks of their behavior really this
hasn't gotten any play in Minneapolis
yeah look it up mm-hmm
yeah how come you don't how come I don't
like what FX twins Oh is is that that
industrial band how come I don't like
them mmm
they're not exactly when I would call
fun um wait I get them confused I'm not
sure exactly I'm lumping them into a
whole genre so you're excuse me for
stereotyping but it's just the kind of
like unrelentless monotonous noise with
little in terms of traditional song
structure for which I myself and I'm
old-fashioned sucker for
yes do my dad and I talk about politics
no no we don't we all we talk about
anymore and my family is my nephew so
like so so every conversation it was
like someone telling what Owen did or
said and the other person saying oh my
god that's so cute
like um I just talked to my sister the
other day and he was in the mail had
come and he was screaming he he likes to
look at catalogs
and and when she calls mailman books and
then I said oh my god that's so cute
yeah you have a follow-up
what's your favorite thing what IRA oh
the question is what is my favorite
thing about IRA Ira Glass my favorite
it's so hard to pick um well I mean just
speaking professionally my favorite
thing about him as a writer is him as an
editor I mean he's really the most
talented editor I have ever had the
pleasure of working with and I just I
mean he's so thorough and he cares so
much and he puts so much heart and humor
and thought into the process that I mean
he sewed he's diligent but he has this
you know whimsy - so I guess my favorite
thing about him is is editing mm-hmm and
the question is have I been Antietam
no have you hmm
yeah on my next vacation where am I
going
um well I I'm I don't know hmm I just
went on one this summer in August
yeah Antietam apparently is getting a
lot of recommendation in August I went
to my mom kind of a Dakota's kick so I
went to I go every year my sister and I
take my nephew to a national park well
since he's born so the last three
summers and so we went to a badlands
national park and we also swung by Mount
Rushmore and Wounded Knee and devils
tower which Owen calls the bear Rock
which okay you know there's some Native
American folk tale about the devil's
tower which is the these girls were
being chased by a bear and the Bears
like clawing at the rock and that's how
the rock became striated and he saw that
picture and so he calls it the bear rock
isn't that cute
you and then whoever you were Conan
O'Brien on a show quite a bit the
question is if I'm chummy with Conan
O'Brien it's very um low-key around
there and yeah I mean I I like him so
much and that show like everyone who
works in that show it's kind of this
weird a zone
I mean it's so night everyone there is
so nice and so smart and funny and
lovable like you're just kind of like
looking around trying to find you know
what kind of alternate reality you've
entered into and not just Conan like his
whole staff is like crazy likeable um so
yes I like him and I guess he must like
me he is likable he's also a huge
history buff so you know when people say
like what are you guys talking about on
the commercial breaks we're talking
about Mussolini
mm-hmm now you know okay and then that
whoever the other pushing person in the
middle was what
when did I realize that I was gonna be a
writer um well it was never really my
goal growing I wasn't growing up or
anything I mean it kind of slowly slowly
dawned on me like I do remember once
when I was uh I was in Holland as an
exchange student and I had to finish up
my last paper before I could go travel
around with my boyfriend and he was
actually there like in the room waiting
for me to finish up the paper so we
could go on our trip but I was like
cracking myself up at my typewriter you
know writing about dish style anyway and
Dutch modernism which is a hoot and and
he said boy you really crack yourself up
writing those papers don't you and I
remember thinking yeah I actually kind
of like this and then I when I got back
to college in might and I started
writing for the college paper
mainly because um I didn't I didn't like
the art reviews in the Montana State
University exponent and I thought I
could do better and so I started writing
um reviews of the vibrant Gallatin
Valley art scene
and but even then like I and then I
still like and I started writing for art
magazines and stuff kind of just as a
hobby but and then I still and I went to
graduate school to be an art historian
to be a professor and I don't know him
how it just kind of slowly I just
started slowly getting more and more
work and that's when I it just kind of
happened
and in fact for a City Pages here in
Minneapolis I did a lot of writing for
them
and 1995 writing about music and books
and and I love that job and I love that
paper and the people there were so smart
and they were and that was where I
really got to kind of try stuff out and
so I am I owe them all big Gani City
Pages yeah question
ooh about who do I like better Jay
Farrar or Jeff Tweedy okay these guys
I'm sure as you know were the former
teammates band members I guess of Uncle
Tupelo and Jay Farrar went straight for
his band called Sun volt his own in
these is easy now Sol and then Jeff
Tweedy of Wilco I got to go with the
Tweety I'm I'm well I'm well coke crazy
not to denigrate mr. farrar he has a
fine voice and you know steered Uncle
Tupelo well especially in the early days
before Jeff Tweedy what's really getting
his legs as a songwriter um but I love
Jeff Tweety's voice I could just listen
to it over and over again I just think
he's so talented and so smart in and I I
love their last record so much so yeah
what about you oh yeah your knee outside
after that no yeah that's true uh there
was someone else of it yeah who else
cracks me up well there's this writer
this short story writer named Matthew
clam I loved his shorts grace yeah Matt
clamu Sam the cat is his book I just
think he's very he's so funny in his
care his stories are kind of told in
this sort of frat guy voice they're
really smart but they're kind of in this
original voice of this sort of kind of
dumb guy
trying to do good but only doing bad and
it kind of reminds me of Curb Your
Enthusiasm in that way and I love Larry
David I think is he's probably the
funniest person certainly on television
right now I think that show is so funny
and that I don't know if anyone saw the
season finale the other night with it
the end with the swearing in the
restaurant that was so simultaneously
crass and joyous it was like these two
emotions at the same time and it was
just the most like fulfilling experience
I love him
and also I love Don Rickles I love Don
Rickles and I saw him in Atlantic City
this summer and man if I were him you
people in the front row would be dead by
now cuz cuz I cuz he would have murdered
you not the ladies actually he's very
courtly the ladies but you guys in your
sweaters
yes yeah I read Killer Angels
I loved Killer Angels and oh the novel
the question is whether I read the shara
novels about Civil War
yeah and so killer Rangers I love
because it's such a great it's also
besides being a you know lofty great
Civil War novel I love that it's
essentially the hero of it is this nerd
the bookworm Joshua Lawrence Chamberlain
the Bowdoin professor who you know holds
on to little round tap little mountain
top with the bayonet siege and all that
and it's essentially this very bookish
guy um is you know is responsible for
saving this crucial part of Gettysburg
so um yeah I recommend it mm-hmm hit him
and then you sorry I was pointing at him
who is my ideal candidate for president
2004 tonigh oh well I don't think like
that I'm a Democrat I mean I my
my no I mean what I I mean I'm still not
exactly a geezer and my heart's been
broken so many times I mean I don't I
actually don't think like that like I
don't sit around hoping um I hope it's
not Lieberman I would if Gore if Gore
runs what I vote for him in the primary
probably do I think he's going to win no
the party apparatus is not behind him
and that's what you need like you know
why not McCain beat bush it's because
the party apparatus wasn't behind McCain
when McCain was clearly the superior
candidate so I mean I saw John Edwards
on The Daily Show a couple weeks ago and
he was funny but he was so young he was
so young looking I don't know um he was
such a baby even compared to how Clinton
looked um so it's still so wide open
right now isn't it but I really don't
have my hopes up I'll like soldier
forward and you know do you know do you
have an ideal candidate ya know uh and
but let me tell you this don't ever give
them your phone number
that's just like if you get anything out
of this evening like take that home yes
this on No oh he was so brave to come up
maybe he just wanted attention that's
always nice but yeah oh that's so sad
now you're just gonna feel the question
we know that you know someone oh hello
you know some of the writers for Buffy
are just wondering if any of your ideas
have made it onto the show oh um I uh
know one writer for Buffy his name's
Doug Petrie
um and no no I've never given him a
single idea though oh my god every time
I see him he can tell I just like bleed
him dry for information yeah I'm sorry
no that would be my dream although there
again it's like with the the Democrats I
really I must not be a very visionary
person because I honestly don't sit
around like wandering and hoping for
things to happen I just kind of like you
know take my lumps as they come hmm you
know I really sorry I don't know why I
must like I'm focused on this side of
the room so much um my head is just
naturally going over there yes I
apologize Oh is there any rivalry
between me and David Sedaris um not for
me but for him yeah
know what I mean is like what no what I
meant by that is
like I bet I would never even dream to
compete with him you know like I mean I
do a lot of readings with him and you
know he there's just no competing with
him there you just like sit back and
like ride the coattails and he's just
like he I don't know if you've ever seen
him do one of these things but he is
like the master of this form and so I
just like try and like when I'm doing a
reading with him I'm usually you know
sitting on the stage too in it and it's
like I get paid for just sitting there
enjoying the same show that you would so
know but he is so competitive even
though he has like eviscerated the
competition in any sense of the word
he's still competitive you know and so I
can feel him like when I'm at the podium
he likes raining so much like I like
reading but when he's ringing I'm
perfectly happy to sit and listen to him
read but when I when I'm reading and I'm
doing a show with him I can feel him
sitting back there just like waiting to
get back up here you know like he loves
it up here so much and um yeah so no I I
have no you know I would never deign to
compete with him but he he certainly
keeps track like if we're in the car
after the show being driven back to the
hotel he'll like catalog the hugeness of
certain laughs I got seriously it's
fascinating I mean that and that's why
and that's one reason he is so good
because he like he like care so much
about every little detail you know and
he's just constantly working on like
he's constantly letting audience ISM
edit his stuff like I did that to to a
certain extent but he really like hones
things down based on how audiences
respond and he really um he really aims
to please and like it's it's pretty
inspiring actually is there someone else
over here yes
this time in history what do I think
future generation will say about this
time in American history um I don't um I
don't know that it sucks I mean like
this the terrorism it probably will get
a lot of play I would imagine
um I don't know and then maybe there'll
be some footnote about the the
reintroduction of garage rock I'm not
sure no no
how we doing okay what instrument did I
play in band and do I still play it oh
well I played several actually um I
played the trumpet and then that I kind
of plateaued on that and then I switched
to baritone horn and valve trombone but
I think there was some overlap there so
there was one period where I was playing
like trumpet in band one baritone horn
in Symphony band and marching band valve
trombone in jazz band percussion in the
orchestra and also maintaining my duties
and the soprano recorder in the postman
recorder ensemble
but the only thing I ever sort of still
kind of play as the recorder yeah
Confederates and as a Tony what's his
name but I never did did you isn't right
I wanted some more words I should look
into that
yes oh the question is who would I like
to be the role models for my nephew um
Oh three to five I guess that leaves out
Joe Strummer um ah hmm Oh three to five
let me think it must be about like the
present so I give him I just give him
twice
mm-hmm um role models gosh I hadn't
thought about that at all
Oh like I mean really I guess because I
mean my parents and mice and my sister
are such good role models and that's who
he spends the bulk of his time with you
know like my my parents are just such
talented grandparents and they really
get down on the floor and you know like
he thinks my mom is funny this is such a
revelation and so I guess you know he
really has such a I mean so I don't
really care about I mean he watches a
lot of movies on video the the Disney of
certainly um and I that doesn't really
bother me right now all he cares about
are dinosaurs and somebody watches
document he like watches a Museum of
Natural History dinosaur documentaries
like he loved that but a siren i I
better think about that too more I think
I gave him a gene Autry's CD because I
feel like every kid should know Gene
Autry he has this great song called
don't be sad little pal
hmm yes oh um the question is about my
voice and I got started well I actually
started as a DJ at my college station
when I was 18 years old um in my
hometown of Bozeman Montana and I mean
I'd grown up with that station it was
such a great station and you know I
think when I signed up for classes there
in Montana State I think I signed up for
the apprentice class to be a DJ before I
signed up for my actual classes I just
so wanted to be part of that radio
station so I did that
off and on all through college and then
um never really thought anything of it
and then in 95 I was writing my first
book that was a diary of listening to
the radio and that's how I met IRA
because he was working on this local
show I liked and then I just kind of
became friends with him and and one
night I was having dinner with him and
was just telling him a story and he he
had started this American life and he
and then at the end of my little you
know anecdote I asked if he could give
me a tape recorder so it wasn't really
any plan and then I just did that first
story and it really worked out and then
I did the second story and you know blah
blah blah another inspirational tale for
young writers
mmm my advice is always mmm try to be in
the right place at the right time
um I guess but it seems uh people are
getting antsy so maybe one more question
oh yeah okay I'll get this guy because
he's so needs to ask it and then I'll
get you because we were standing up but
being quiet yes Oh in regards to gun
control what did I think of Michael
Moore's new movie I have not seen this
movie but man oh man I was just doing my
book tour in Canada maybe this is like
Canada annex but people in Canada are
crazy for that movie because you know
it's all about like how violent and
stupid we are
I guess mmm so I haven't seen it
unfortunately it is yes you there mm-hmm
this is the last question so you better
make it good but I've got a follow-up oh
do you have a favorite website do I have
a favorite website let's see there's
yeah well I have several um well I love
the onion website the onion and I also
like this TV website called television
without pity where um the people on it
are just so smart and funny and they
just really care about TV and they write
these synopses even if you don't watch a
show just reading their synopses of show
us they're just so funny and so
opinionated and I also I really like
that I like the the Buffy discussion
board the bronze because these people I
mean I would never deign to actually
write something on it but these people
are so in the world of the show but they
like they it's kind of this incredible
model of knowledge gathering because of
their level like the show exit of
knowledge exists on so many different
levels so like when they were discussing
whether the character of Tara
who
been murdered what could be resurrected
the discussion was like no remember how
they broke the urn of whatever it's
called that was the urn they used to
resurrect Buffy in episode whatever and
and then someone else is like yeah and I
also read in variety that her [ __ ] the
actresses contract had not been renewed
so it's just this like you know like
using all the Olly like knowledge they
have available to them to make an
educated guess about whether a fake
person could be brought back to fake
life or like oh I loved it when um last
year when when Buffy slept with Spike
the vampire spike and it was the
probably the most pornographic thing I'd
ever seen on regular TV in a good way
and and but it was pretty like they were
it's Buffy and Spike worse were fighting
and they were having this knock-down
drag-out fight and then it kind of
turned and then they were you know doing
it and then but the discussion board was
really funny the next day because there
are some you know because some of the
people on the border younger and others
are older and some of the young girls on
it were like it wasn't romantic at all
and then some of the older people are
like well there are different kinds of
sex
but also another website I really like
is the focus on the family website where
they write about movies and they kind of
judge it's the Dobson you know it's like
a it's a fundamentalist Christian
website but the film reviews I love
because they actually review movies like
something is at stake you know and they
talk about how would this make you feel
how would this make your kids feel what
how will this affect you which you know
is not like normal criticism and all but
I really like how they actually care
about what these things are saying and
talk about you know how they relate to
their point of view and so as a way of
writing it so it's incredibly
fascinating so those are just the kind
of high minded things that I do like to
look at on the internet yeah have you
ever bought or sold anything on eBay
have I ever but or sold anything on eBay
no I have not I really like though um
there's I won't do a product placement
because I'm not getting reimbursed for
it but there is one one of your major
booksellers on on the internet has this
thing in Manhattan which is same-day
delivery which is if you place an order
by 11:00 a.m. it will arrive at your
door by 7:00 I just think this is a sign
of civilization like I love this feature
so much and I love I love shopping on
the Internet
I love it because you don't have to talk
to anyone
and anyway and on that note uh but I'm
not you I love talking to strangers and
in every other way so thank you very
much this is very memorable
you